hello and welcome back to another video
today we're going to be talking about a
movie called a silent voice the movie
starts with a boy who decides to quit
his part-time job and sells all of his
belongings for which he gets 3 000 yen
in total he withdraws all that money
from the bank places it in an envelope
and puts it beside the bed of a woman to
whom he owes that money the boy is about
to jump from a bridge but suddenly he
stops he's distracted by the kids who
are lighting fireworks he crosses the
date on the calendar and heads back home
we're taken into a flashback of sixth
grade elementary school students and a
group of three friends among who's rmc
shoya the dominant one who's good at
everything and is popular as well at
school a new student joins the class and
the teacher asks her to introduce
herself she opens her backpack and takes
out a notebook her name is shoko and she
asks everyone to use her notebook to
talk to her she also lets the class know
that she can't hear
later all the girls gather around shoko
and try to communicate with her the
teacher's giving a lecture but shulker
can't hear what he's saying one of the
girls asks her to hand over her notebook
to help her understand what's going on
next up in the music class the girl once
again struggles to feel included she
starts singing but is told that she's
singing too fast one of the girls says
that she'll help her with her timing the
next day in class the teacher randomly
asks different students to read now it's
shoko's turn to read but her speech is
different and sounds strange then it's
joya's turn to read he mocks the girl by
reading the same way
[Music]
as shoko tries to fit in with the rest
of the class she becomes an easy target
for shoya and his pals to bully he
throws dirt in the girl's eye when she
asks him to become friends to help shoko
fit in communicate and learn the school
decides to teach the class sign language
all students must attend three minute
lessons in sign language each morning
one of the students named sahara
volunteers to help shoko shoya and the
rest of the gang find another
opportunity to bully shoko he writes
some hurtful stuff on the board and
pretends someone else has done it he
even erases it for her shoko unaware of
his intentions thanks him for erasing
the message the next day in class shoya
yells into shoko's ears and she gets
startled everyone's surprised that she
can hear the girl with the blackhead
named naoko later checks shoko's ears
and finds out that she's wearing a
hearing aid the girl asks her to show
her the hearing aid and throws him
towards shoya who throws them outside
the deaf girl becomes a victim of
shoya's bullying every day in different
forms one day things go too far and
shoko starts bleeding for which the boy
gets into trouble after when shoya and
his friends are about to leave for home
shoko confronts them and has a message
for them which is written down on her
notebook she says i am sorry and that
she and shoya are friends shawya doesn't
like that he throws away a notebook in
the fountain water and continues to walk
away shulker gets inside the puddle of
water to pull out her notebook the next
day the principal addresses the class
and informs everyone that shoko is
absent today they received a call from
her mother who told them that eight of
her hearing aids have gone missing or
been damaged the principal also informs
the class that the girl's mother has
complained that she's being bullied at
school he asks all the students to let
him know if they've witnessed shoko
being bullied or become a victim of
harassment her hearing aids are quite
expensive and the one responsible for
this can get in a lot of trouble
therefore it's best to come out on their
own the teacher speaks up he asks troyer
to stand up because everyone knows it's
him who's been bullying the girl when
shoya says he wasn't the only one all
his friends turn against him shoya's
mother receives a call from the school
she asks shoya to prepare to meet the
girl and apologize to her on their way
she withdraws money from the bank and
gives it to the girl's mother for the
damage soya has caused to her hearing
aid showa's mother advises him to be a
good boy from tomorrow now the tables
have turned shawya becomes the victim of
bullying he finds shoko in the classroom
cleaning his desk after all that's
happened the boy's surprised to see her
smile he believes she's faking it she
must be angry and that she's pretending
to be a good girl as a result the two
get into a fight and start hitting each
other shorkor's now moved to another
school shoya discovers and saves a
notepad that shoko left behind fast
forward a few years later shoya a
melancholy loner who can't look others
in the eyes and imagines an x sign over
the faces of people has been an outcast
since middle school for his reputation
as a bully to tie up the loose ends the
boy goes to the sign language club there
he spots a girl with long hair who looks
similar to shoko he reaches out to her
and introduces himself shoko smiles
again but tries to run after the brief
encounter shoya runs after her and says
he came to give her the notebook that
she left back in school he used his sign
language to talk to her shoko stand to
learn that the boy who practically
refused to learn sign language now knows
it the girl gets all teared up upon
receiving the notebook in sign language
shoya tells her that they can be friends
wait a second the boy now realizes what
she used to say back to him in the
school days alas it was a dream the boy
was dreaming about making amends with
the deaf girl next morning shoya has
breakfast with his mother who's pleased
to receive the money she happens to know
about her son's attempt to jump from a
bridge and brings it up at the table she
yells at him and asks him to promise
that he'll never do it again surya soon
realizes that he's got to take
responsibility for what he did to shoko
and hence has isolated himself from
everything even his friends had turned
their back on him another loner domohiro
befriends shoya after he saves him from
a bully the two become friends and start
hanging out often shoya tries to see
shoko by visiting her at school but
shoko's friend yuzuru doesn't let him
see her when he tries to talk to her the
second time domohiro pops up out of
nowhere he's been following his friend
and asks yuzuru to allow the two to meet
finally the two meeting shoya tells her
that he's been looking for an excuse to
meet her for a really long time shoko
tells that she wanted to meet him too
and together the two begin feeding bread
to the fish in the river while they're
talking shoko wanted to read her old
notebook but shoya doesn't want her to
remember the past and tries to take it
hence the notebook accidentally falls
into the river the girl jumps into the
river to retrieve it and shoya follows
her they managed to grab the notebook
and climb out of the river safely shoko
tells shoya that they'll see each other
again unhappy with everything that's
happened yuzuru takes a photo of shoya
jumping in and puts it online as a form
of revenge the next day everyone in
school is talking about this incident
and showing us stunned to see his
picture posted online since jumping into
the river is illegal shoya gets a
suspension for this act
shorya comes across yuzuru who's run
away from home hiding in the kids
playground sleeping in one of the boxes
shoya wonders if yuzuru is shoko's
boyfriend as they talk yuzuru confesses
about the picture posted online shoya
who was out in the park with maria his
sister's kid asks yuzuru to go home as
he leaves the park too uzuru is too
tight to get up so he drags and takes
uzuru home to give him something to eat
it's night time and everyone's asleep
yuzuru remembers shoko's words to
apologize for posting the picture or
else to leave home saddened by what
happened yuzuru goes outside shoya
follows uzuru out of the door in the
middle of the night he lends his old
shoes and asks the reason for running
away from home yuzuru confesses about an
argument with shoko the two reconcile
and become friends before leaving yuzuru
tells shoya that she's not shoko's
boyfriend that she's actually her sister
by which he gets embarrassed suddenly
shoko's mother comes and slaps him later
at home she tells the girls to stay away
from shoya shoya and shoko reunite with
a former classmate sahara who was kind
to shoko in elementary school shoya
leaves the girls and while walking he
meets naoka later she finds shoya while
riding the bike who is observing shoko
from afar naoka runs towards shoko and
removes her hearing aid but shoya stops
her he tells narugo that they're friends
but she doesn't believe him and leaves
the next day shoko subsequently gives
shoya a gift and confesses her feelings
for him but shoya misunderstands her
since she attempts to voice her feelings
rather than sign them out later the boy
invites shotgun to a theme park with
sahara tomohiro miki who is another
elementary school classmate and miki's
friend they're joined there by naoka who
leads shoko into a ferris wheel naoka
expresses a dislike for shoko accusing
her of causing a wedge between her and
shoya
back at home yuzuru who was secretly
filming the encounter shows shoya the
footage of it miki discloses shoya's
pass to the kids who are unaware of it
desperate to avoid being held
responsible for her role in tormenting
shoko after the leak later she tries to
apologize to the group but shoya
dismisses everyone after naoka's
dismissive attitude shoya discovers
shoko and yuzuru's grandmother had
recently passed away showing us
heartbroken to see the two of them so
tense and gloomy he decides to take them
to the countryside to cheer them up
where he discovers that shoko blames
herself for everything that has happened
to him shoya makes the decision to focus
his entire life on the sisters shoko
travels home under the pretense of
finishing schoolwork during a fireworks
event when uzuru asks him to get her
camera shoya obliges when he comes he
finds shoko on the balcony trying to do
something stupid but shoya manages to
catch her and drag her to safety but he
falls into the river below he's saved by
his former elementary school best
buddies unfortunately he falls into a
coma shoko meets with each of the group
members to discuss her and shorya's
problems in the hopes of assisting shoya
naoka accuses shoko about what happened
to shoya and tries to slap her but
shoko's mother comes and stops her shoko
sees a dream about showing her paying
her a farewell visit one night she
rushes to the bridge terrified and
collapses shaw wakes up from his coma
and wanders to the bridge where he finds
shoko he apologizes for how he treated
her asking her to stop blaming herself
shoya then asks her to help him in
staying alive and she agrees
shorya is reunited with his pals when he
returns to school and he realizes how
much they still care about him sure
discovers that he can finally look
people in the eyes again when he
visualizes the x marks fading away as
the pals attend the school festival
together shoya sobs as he looks around
his family and all his new friends
knowing that he's finally atoned for his
sins and then the movie ends so this is
it for today's video if you like the
video give it a huge thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel for more videos
farewell till next time